beaucoup d'entreprises de combustibles fossiles aiment
faire des affaires au Texas parce que les
lois environnementales sont très faibles et souvent
non appliquées.
[Musique] [
Musique]
vous avez
des
rejets toxiques de plusieurs millions de gallons par jour
dans cette région et donc en ce moment, cela
affecte les
pêcheries
là-bas  Avant, il y avait probablement
quatre ou cinq six cents pêcheurs dans
cette communauté et maintenant,
il y a de la chance s'il y en a plus d'une
poignée.
[Musique]
depuis l'an 2000 donc au cours des 21 dernières
années, euh, Formosa Plastics Group, c'est
toutes ses filiales et  les filiales
de différents pays
ont payé au total un
peu plus de 560 millions de dollars d'amendes
[Musique]
vous